Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the batman
movie for wonder woman 1984 the suicide
squad movie justice league snyder cut
all the big panels
and trailers and footage that are going
to be coming at dc fandom in a little
while
i'll be doing videos for all that stuff
so be sure to subscribe to get it i'll
do special giveaways as part of that too
i had to sign a bunch of forms
so warner brothers and dc are sending me
a giant box of stuff in the next week
i'll be doing special giveaways as part
of all those videos and i'll explain the
schedule for when everything is going to
be releasing at the end of the video too
but just going down the list starting
with number five starting with the
batman movie panel
no surprise that it's the last one of
the night they always save the biggest
panels at comic-con because this is sort
of a replacement for comic-con
for the end of the night on saturday
matt reeves and robert pattinson are
going to be there answering questions
talking about the movie it's a
pre-recorded panel so they've already
made it but they did announce they'd be
bringing some special surprises which
most people believe is going to be more
test footage
similar to the teaser trailer from
earlier this year where they showed off
robert pattinson in the new batman suit
for the first time
with the new version of the batman theme
music michael giaccino's composing
this time since we've already seen early
looks at the new batmobile we'll
probably get some cool new previews of
that and of course catwoman in the
villains in full costume the riddler
penguin
carmine even though the movie is based
on the long halloween comic story though
i'm not expecting catwoman to wear the
purple long halloween suit
there's a lot of fan art of zoe
kravitz's catwoman out there that i
think is
pretty close and relatively accurate to
what she's going to look like during the
movie
and if you didn't realize earlier this
year we already saw footage of catwoman
but it's
her riding with batman on their bikes
through the cemetery
and she's wearing a black jacket and a
helmet and it's her stunt woman and it's
robert pattinson stunt man in that
batman suit
so it kind of gave us a hint for her
character in the movie plus we've seen
zoey kravitz walking around in real life
with that short selena kyle hair dude
that she's been sporting
they haven't been filming that much on
the movie that's why i don't think
they've cut
a real traditional trailer or anything
like that originally when the movie was
still going to be released next
summer the first real trailer wasn't
supposed to come till december so
everything's just been delayed a little
bit
right now the movie is coming out in
october so we could get more footage in
december or they could just hold footage
until they release the justice league
snyder cut next spring and attach a
batman trailer to that
but recently they were talking about
what's going on in the movie the writer
was talking about how they explore
batman's trauma in a much bigger way
than previous batman movies had
the way he and matt reeves have talked
about it the movie is about
batman's soul or the battle for batman's
soul that he metaphorically wages while
he's also battling the villains
you could draw some similarities to the
stuff that zack snyder was setting up
during batman v superman with ben
affleck's batman in the dead robin
costume all the implications about his
past
why he stopped being batman for a period
of time before superman and the
kryptonians showed up during the man of
steel movie
they would have explored a lot of that
part of batman's trauma during the ben
affleck version of the batman movie when
he was still part of the project a
couple years ago
i've already done a couple videos about
what the plot of that movie was going to
be
it would have been vastly different in
tone and look from the matt reeves
robert pattinson
batman movie but i think so much stuff
is being added back into the justice
league snyder cut that movie is going to
be over four hours long
we might get a lot of that lost batman
storyline as part of the snyder cut
so number four obviously there's the
justice league snyder cut panel
zack snyder and henry cavill are
supposed to be there with some of the
other justice league actors
some of them are also doing their
separate panels for other movies like
gal gadot is doing a wonder woman 1984
panel
i don't think that ben affleck is going
to be there but that's fine
zack snyder has already been posting a
ton of previews of the trailer footage
that he's going to be showing off
he hasn't said if it's going to be just
a really long clip like extended footage
when he released that big justice league
clip back in 2016 at comic con or if
it's going to be more traditional
trailer but it should be pretty badass
he's been hyping up all the special
effects the redesigns of steppenwolf and
hyping up darkseid
so it's possible we also see some more
dark side deleted scenes in addition to
the dark side scene that he released a
few months ago
i've already done a video on that
trailer so i'll put a link in the
description
and i will put links in the description
for all the different trailers that they
release
i've already done a ton of videos on
what's going to be in the snyder cut and
how the story lines are different from
the theatrical cut
there was a whole black suit superman
scene that he released a few weeks ago
in all the green lantern scenes that
he's been teasing since they first
announced the project
zack snyder was also teasing the way
they're planning on actually releasing
the movie so he said that they could
release it as just a giant four hour
movie on hbo max or they could break it
up into a couple different episodes and
air it weekly for a couple weeks
they'll reveal all those details next
week at the big panel
but as of right now i don't think
there's any big plans for zack snyder to
come back and do any brand new dc movies
or tv series
that could always change i mean never
say never but i think right now
just the plans are for him to do the
snyder cut and that's it
for those of you that were asking about
all the ben affleck rumors that ben
affleck's stuff kind of went out the
window when they announced that michael
keaton was coming back
to cross over into all the new dc movies
and be the de facto multiverse batman
from the tim burton movies
so number three the flash flashpoint
movie panel and michael keaton batman
the producers and the director have
already explained the basic plot of the
movie and the major news outlets have
already explained
warner brothers overall plans for
michael keaton's batman in the new
movies
some of that could always change down
the road just depending on scheduling
issues
but you've all seen or read a version of
the justice league flashpoint storyline
so you know kind of how that story moves
they're not using it to retcon out ben
affleck's batman of the dc eu or
anything like that
even though keaton is becoming the new
batman of the dc eu temporarily
just because robert pattinson's batman
of the matt reeves batman movie
is supposed to be in a separate
continuity i know it sounds confusing
there's going to be at least
three new batmen on screen in the next
year you have michael keaton's batman in
the flash movie you have ben affleck
coming back in the justice league snyder
cut and then robert pattinson's batman
in the batman movie in october
it'll be a really good time to be a
batman fan next year
absolutely zero coincidence that i just
updated my social media profile pictures
the way they talk about changing the
flashpoint storyline though they're not
going to do the big atlantis wonder woman
aquaman war it'll be a much smaller
version of that storyline
and they haven't explained how they're
going to fold in michael keaton's batman
to the original thomas wayne parts of
the flashpoint story
because thomas wayne isn't supposed to
be in the flashpoint movie
right now i'm just expecting a flash of
two worlds type of twist because ezra
miller keeps talking about
being a multiverse flash crossing over
in other universes
so the flash of two worlds is just the
story of how the flash in the comics
accidentally wound up on earth 2 meeting
jay garrick but it sounds like in the
flashpoint movie it'll be him winding up
in the batcave of michael keaton's
batman he thinks he's going to visit the
ben affleck batman but accidentally
winds up in keaton's bat cave
they haven't confirmed all the other
movies that keaton is supposed to cross
over into besides the flash movie
only the batman beyond plans that they
have in the future live action batman
beyond
down the road eventually cyborg is also
supposed to be a huge part of the flash
movie ezra miller's flash even
referenced him when talking to grant
gustin's flash during that crisis on
infinite earth's cameo scene
just as he's disappearing he says he was
talking to victor as in victor stone aka
cyborg about the existence of the
multiverse
zack snyder also said that in the
original justice league sequel plans
cyborg would have been the one to help
flash make the time travel calculations
in order to go back and
warn batman to save lois lane so that
they could save superman from being
emceed by darkseid in the anti-life
equation
that was what they were setting up with
that nightmare scene from batman v
superman so
hopefully they'll pay that off during
the justice league snyder cut this is
actually what that time travel suit
looked like
and i'm expecting them to introduce a
brand new flash suit during the flash
movie
but number two then there's the wonder
woman 1984 panel in the suicide squad
movie panel
they're going to be dropping a new
trailer for wonder woman 1984 cheetah
will be
in it i know they've been saving so much
of her for last i'm assuming that's
mostly because they've been tuning the
special effects for her character
because she sort of evolves into
cheetahs the movie goes along these are
some of the recent clips that they've
released that have some cheetah stuff in
it
they're really holding back with the
cheetah stuff but the movie is supposed
to come out in october there's always
the possibility that they have to delay
it again
but because disney is doing that big
experiment with mulan releasing it on
disney plus in a couple weeks no less
if that goes well for them financially
then there's always the chance that
warner brothers tries a hybrid release
schedule where it comes out in theaters
some places and video on demand other
places
but james gunn is doing a really big
suicide squad movie panel with most of
the cast
hopefully you'll be able to see john
cena on screen post all the memes in the
comments
he did tease that there'd be a first
look at the movie i don't know if that's
going to be a full trailer or a teaser
trailer or some test footage but we'll
probably get a look at the characters in
their costumes
the number one there is a mystery panel
that they're doing for a surprise
unannounced movie that they're going to
be revealing for the first time the
panel is only 15 minutes long so it's
super quick
but this could either be the new green
lantern core movie that they're still
making but haven't talked about in a
while the green lantern hbo series that
they've already teased and a lot of
people i know are hoping for a new
superman man of steel movie announcement
but i don't think that that's going to
happen
we'll find out though there is a secret
mystery movie that they will be
revealing next weekend
anything that i don't get to on saturday
i'll just do videos for on sunday or
monday
so no worries as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
all those videos when i post them
but congratulations to brian clark
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big dc video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your details
everyone click here for that brand new
wonder woman 1984 trailer and click here
for that other
batman trailer thank you so much for
watching everyone stay
safe i'll see you guys tonight!